yeah we understand that the prime
minister will resign today look i spoke
to a cabinet minister this morning who
had seen the prime minister had a long
conversation with him yesterday and said
to the prime minister the game is up you
simply do not have the numbers uh to
fill posts in your government the
country will be ungovernable you cannot
carry on uh he tried to hold on last
night you saw the reports
on the news but as we understand it this
morning let me just get the statement up
from on my phone uh that boris johnson
we understand has spoken to the tory uh
party chair or committee chair 22 chair
graeme brady and agreed to stand down so
we're going to expect a resignation for
from boris johnson later today it's over
for him he tried until the very end to
hold on but when you're faced with over
50 government resignations half a dozen
of your cabinet walking out and finding
yourself unable to fill even cabinet
positions with ministers uh i'm willing
to be promoted with parliamentarians
unwilling to serve
that's when your government collapses
the game is up for boris johnson he's
going to have to stand down
okay beth so
what happens
no unprecedented times the helicopters
are already up the street has gone
absolutely bonkers what happens tonight
well what we will expect to happen now
is the prime minister will be in there
this morning he will be with his
advisers he will be drafting a
resignation statement
and we'll expect to hear from him later
that will then of course trigger
a leadership race within the
conservative party and i think what is
difficult about this one compared to the
moment that theresa may resigned in 2019
was back in 2019
there was a clear
successor to tresemme it was boris
johnson and he went on to win that
leadership race and a runoff against
jeremy hunt but this time
the field is wide open
politicians are not ousting boris
johnson because of a policy policy
disagreement as they did over may
regarding brexit and they don't really
have a plan of what comes next or who
they would like to be leader they are
literally ousting him because they
cannot serve under him and it's just got
too bad being in a boris
johnson cabinet government and even
parliamentary party and so what will
happen now is he will resign and then
there will be a leadership contest and
in the coming days we will see all the
runners and riders coming out to make
their pitch
to the parliamentary party we've already
had overnight sawela bravo man she's the
attorney general the most senior legal
mind in government
she has
announced overnight that she uh would
like uh to run
we've got rishi sunak we've got sajid
javid we've got tom tuggenheart the
chair of the foreign affairs select
committee who is perhaps the favored
choice of the one nation group of
conservatives in the party what about
brandon lewis the northern ireland
secretary that just resigned nadim
zahari penny morden i have got such a
long list of would-be runners and riders
and then we're going to have a
competition uh to see who uh takes the
job but it comes at such a difficult
time
for the country given the cost of living
crisis and the difficulties that
households up and down the land
have are having and i've just got an
official number 10 statement just out
the prime minister will make a statement
to the country today so boris johnson
will make a statement today it is over
for him he won the biggest majority
didn't he back in 2019 of any
conservative prime minister since
margaret thatcher he was potentially a
two-term president uh prime minister but
after two and a half years uh his reign
has come to an end and boris johnson is
standing down as conservative party
leader and prime minister
well it's the moment in history again
beth isn't it you've witnessed so many
for us already as our political editor
um
when do you think we will hear from him
when will he make that statement and in
what capacity do we know yet
i don't know yet kay what i do know is
as i've said there is now an official
statement
saying that boris johnson will make a
statement to the country later
and as i was saying earlier he has
spoken to sir graham brady who went to
see him yesterday the chair of the 22
back bench committee and agreed to stand
down as a party leader so a new leader
can be in place by party conference so
that is in october
at the end of september into october a
new party leader in place uh for the
autumn summer
he will remain prime minister until that
point so i've just been told by a number
10 figure the prime minister is now
agreeing to an orderly handover of power
so instead of fighting on he's now
agreed to resign he's told brian brady
of his intentions and he will remain
prime minister over the summer while
that leadership race is played out
and they hope to have a new prime
minister and conservative party leader
by the autumn so
the summer recess is going to be taken
up by a lot of campaigning by would-be
new prime ministers and conservative
party leaders is such an incredible
moment
we could see really
as i was saying a couple of days ago
that his time was up when those
resignations happened in cabinet that
was perhaps the moment
and then the snowball in effect over the
12 hours following when dozens of
government resignations began
to fall in and cabinet members then went
didn't they yesterday in a delegation to
tell boris johnson he had to go but even
last night number 10 were briefing of
his defiance telling me that he was
going to call sir gray and brady's bluff
that he was going to force a confidence
vote in him well overnight and as dawn
broke and more people resigned brandon
lewis standing down as northern ireland
secretary and then nadim sahari telling
the prime minister that he had to go
and then we had michelle donald also the
education secretary the game up for
boris johnson however hard he fought
however much he wanted it it was simply
not tenable for him to continue